poor ago what'd you think well I think
it's a little girl be lovely wouldn't it
be better for everybody
have you got a choice of name have I got
a choice of name now I know just be
looking at grace how about great
princess gray nothing's gonna be
Princess Grace but dinorah being there
somewhere
Shirley yeah I think it's gonna be a boy
dude okay we got your blue coat on yeah
but I've got pink on underneath I just
thought you sure it'd be a great timing
about 11 o'clock tomorrow morning Marva
certainly brilliant and then we can we
can get on with our lives
yeah lovely Fanny had a long wait didn't
you we found out that it was a boys sort
of 8 o'clock at night wasn't it yeah the
holidays are you waiting room yeah we
were we were a memories finally were
rewarded with that fantastic picture
even with the baby waving as they came
out I think the whole thing seems to be
perfectly organized ready for you know
Monday the Queen arrives at Kensington
Palace then they off to an Mahal it's
all over yeah